today's one minute monday is stop being
close-minded I just put up my newsletter
and was talking about stop being
mediocre and help people settle for
average and they said for okay and I
shared advice and wisdom from Ivanka
Trump who's an entrepreneur and it
happens to be the daughter of Donald
Trump and one of my subscribers writes
back and says that he doesn't take it
seriously because Ivanka Trump is part
of the what did he call it lucky sperm
Club because her father's famous and
that's why she's successful that blows
my mind how people limit themselves and
close them off to success and to wisdom
from other people just because Ivanka
Trump is the daughter of Donald Trump
that means you can't learn from her just
because somebody has successful rich
parents that means they don't have
wisdom to offer you to help you it's
crazy you know Bill Gates was my first
mentor was the first person that I
looked up to in the world of
entrepreneurship his strategies helped
save my company Bill Gates was a sign of
rich parents Bill Gates had access to
computers when no other kid did because
his parents were able to get him that
time and now Bill Gates has gone on to
build one of the most successful
companies in the world and I'm not
supposed to learn from him because he
had wealthy parents are you kidding me
it just blows my mind how people close
themselves off to learning opportunities
they're so close minded you're only
willing to learn from a certain kind of
person it doesn't matter what color
their skin is it doesn't matter what
economic class are coming from it
doesn't matter what their gender is it
doesn't matter what country they live in
success leaves clues and you can learn
from every successful person if you're
only willing to learn from this specific
kind of person then you're limiting
yourself
so open your mind and believe don't
forget to sign up for my free newsletter
its energy in your inbox every single
week hi I'm Jason j-rod fonseka of ra's
online com and i want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and XD only newsletter i
prioritize and look forward to period